das hier war allerdings mein favorit ja
ein etwas jüngerer junge im südkorea
trikot alter ohne spaß der hat sich
locker 50 mikrowellen angeschaut der hat
die aufgemacht reingeguckt wieder
zugemacht und dann immer einmal
geschnitzt am ende hat der typ leider
nichts gekauft
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja bald ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's gut ich freue mich
wirklich auf das heutige video vor ich
habe es doch mal nachgeschaut genau fünf
tagen kam ein video die person vor mir
darf entscheiden was ich esse für die
die das jetzt nicht gesehen haben und
auch keinen plan haben was damit gemeint
ist also an sich ging es halt darum dass
ich mir irgendwo etwas zu essen holen
und immer genau das gleiche bestellt
habe wie die person vor mir jetzt
irgendwie so ein drive dann habe ich
halt zum drive arbeiter gesagt gib mir
doch bitte einfach genau das gleiche wie
die person die da vor dem auto ist ja
das hört sich ein bisschen komisch an
ich hätte gerne einmal genau das was der
vor mir hatte geht das ja ja genau der
vor mir das video ist echt lustig bei
euch angekommen falls ihr das so nicht
gesehen habt schaut euch das sehr gerne
an und darauf kann man jetzt weiter
aufbauen ich habe darunter ein paar
richtig coole kommentare gelesen wie zum
beispiel mach das mal am flughafen und
sagt dass so eine fluglärms wie die
person vor dir könnte man eigentlich
auch noch machen oder wenn ihr darauf
gehofft dass ich erst mal machen gibt er
gern nach oben 1 kommentar um den es
allerdings heute geht das ist in dieser
hier und zwar macht es mal im mediamarkt
ich dachte mir halt erst so kann ich
eigentlich nicht machen ich meine das
wird der steuer wenn ich pech hatte
allerdings ein bisschen länger darüber
nachgedacht und bin jetzt zum entschluss
gekommen warum machst du das nicht
einfach mal weil sich das irgendwie dumm
an ich muss dazu auch erstmal was
erklären damit ihr das video versteht
also es wäre schon wichtig wenn ihr
jetzt dranbleiben und zwar erste sache
wir machen dass ich bei media
markt/saturn einfach weil die saturn und
hier viel näher ist und mediamarkt alter
da muss irgendwie in die stadt laut ich
glaube es gibt auch nur einigen können
deswegen gehen wir zur natur zweite
sache ich habe mir ganz klar ein
budgetgesetz von 500 euro einfach alles
was über 500 euro ist springt dann
meiner meinung
rahmen und wer hat schon viel geld so
muss man ganz ehrlich sagen ich hoffe
das versteht ihr trotzdem ist die video
idee wir gehen gleich ein spannender
saturn und kaufen dann genau das hatte
ich schon verrückt anderen kaufen dann
genau das gleiche wie die personen vor
mir und jetzt passt auch ich sag mal so
wenn bei mir ein video ungefähr so 130
140000 news macht vielleicht auch sagen
wir 150 news hatte ich meistens davon
ausgehen damit werden ungefähr ich habe
eine relativ gute cpm 4 500 dollar
umgesetzt das ist ein richtwert die
nicht nur mal setzte das heißt wenn wir
mit diesem video hat 500 dollar umsetzen
kann ich diese 500 euro ausgeben
dann ist es halt ein video was
eigentlich 0 geschäft ist jetzt fragt
ihr euch sicherlich wieso ist es dann 0
geschäft ich meine du hast ja das
produkt und das geld aber ich habe mir
gedacht um das ganze kohle zu machen
interessanter zu gestalten und eventuell
auch noch weitere parks davon zu machen
ihr könnt gerne mal irgendwelche
kaufhäuser oder irgendwelche geschäfte
eben welche marken in die kommentare
schreiben
werde ich das produkt oder vielleicht
auch die produkte kommt darauf an was da
die person von macau einfach immer dann
verlosen also alle die das video schauen
ihr könnt dann halt daran teilnehmen ich
will jetzt will ich am liebsten direkt
los fahren trotzdem wenn ihr sagt hey
das produkt gefällt mir wenn ihr halt so
okay das ist jetzt geworden
dann müsst ihr einfach abonnent seien
vom kanal sag immer um geld aber wer
halt auch dumm wenn es nicht sein
unkommentiert bitte unten in den
kommentaren mit eurem instagram namen
eurem facebook nahm der beste ist
eigentlich instagram name wenn ihr das
nicht habt dann meinetwegen mit eurer
emailadresse oder so einfach aus
erfahrung dass ich euch dann leichter
erreichen kann wenn ihr gewinnen sollte
das war es eigentlich mehr wirklich
nicht sagen also ich bin gespannt
welches produkt oder welche produkt ist
werden ich bin auch gespannt ob es
schwer wird überhaupt schnell was zu
finden weil die meisten leute schauen
halt nur und dann würde ich sagen letzte
euro ab im auto
marie kommt auch noch mit die kann man
da so leicht sehen musste mal wieder
warten eigentlich wäre schon längst
fertig gewesen
allerdings hieß also ab geht's rein zu
saturn was die karte hinter ganz liebe
tor einschenken
ich werde das ganze natürlich nur mit
meinem handy film weil ja gut wenn mich
jemand fragt entschuldung warum fünfte
mich ja ich brauche das ein
youtube-video ich will gerade das
gleiche kaufen was du auch kopf und ich
muss die menschen natürlich auch
verlassen wir auch draußen weil sonst
gibt es nach ärger weil die haben diese
kamera natürlich auch im sortiment keine
ahnung vielleicht ist das so
keine ahnung vielleicht wenn jetzt
manche in die kommentare schreiben dass
das ja nicht stimmt aber ich habe keinen
kassenzettel und so dabei deswegen man
muss ja nichts riskieren also nur das
hätte nicht wird mitgenommen und der
rest wird dokumentiert ich würde sagen
metzger leute und jetzt folgt der ein
ständiger aufenthalt im saturn hier sind
wir so gerade auf dem weg rein zu gehen
und dann waren wir auch schon drin
direkt am anfang waren so zwei jungs da
die war die staaten bestimmt zehn
minuten vor diesen spielen und der eine
typ hat sich auch im spiel ausgesucht
der hat es gekauft hab ich gesagt
welches ist und das spiel nannte sich
battle von das problem war am ende ich
habe das nicht nur gefunden das war
irgendwie das letzte spiel leute den typ
habe ich ja auch direkt verfolgt der war
irgendwie total waschmaschine orientiert
also wer hat sich eine waschmaschine
nach der anderen am ende hat er aber
leider keine waschmaschine gekauft um
ehrlich zu sein war ich auch froh drüber
ich mein was will jemand von euch mit
einer waschmaschine und wie zufällig
eine waschmaschine verschicken das hier
war allerdings mein favorit ja ein etwas
jüngerer junge in südkorea trikot alter
ohne spaß der hat sich locker 50
mikrowellen angeschaut der hat die
aufgemacht reingeguckt wieder zugemacht
und dann immer einmal geschnitzt am ende
hat der typ leider nichts gekauft leute
ich habe die suche schon fast aufgegeben
doch bin dann irgendwie auf seine
familie aufmerksam geworden ganz hinten
in der ecke weil im fernsehen die hatten
sich auch schon einen fernseher
rausgepickt und da wurde heiß diskutiert
was dieser fernseher denn alles kann da
habe ich dann auch ein kommentar dazu
abgegeben wundert euch nicht irgendwie
war die handykamera angesucht habe ich
erst später gemerkt sorry deutschland
ist so eine familie die kaufen und
fernsehen
also zumindest sind die gerade dabei ich
versuche daraus wegen welcher das ist
weil er sei nicht ganz nice aber wo
steht er dann warte da sind auch noch
welche eine vision zu groß würde ich
glaube ich habe den fernseher gefunden
ich bin mir aber nicht ganz sicher
nachdem sich die familie bestimmt eine
halbe stunde lang über den fernseher
informiert hat wurde endlich eingepackt
und zur kasse manövriert gegen die hat
mein handy dann nicht mehr richtig
aufgenommen ich konnte euch jetzt noch
dieses foto hier raus suchen da sieht
man die familie an der kasse wie sie den
fernseher kaufen
ich bin an zur mitarbeiter gegangen und
habe gesagt ich hätte gerne einmal
diesen fernseher der wie ein bisschen
druck und hat dann einfach diesen
fernseher geholt den die gerade vorher
gekauft haben die man hier sieht
ich habe mich dann wirklich sehr über
den fernseher gefreut wurde noch kurz
net verabschiedet habe dann hier den
fernseher gekauft und ja das war es dann
auch von meinem einstündigen saturn
aufenthalt und ist schwer
schon könnten
so gedacht was du so was großes heute
kauf also mir war schon klar ist
irgendwas elektronisches führte
also leute ich muss wirklich sagen wir
machen jetzt lockt eine stimmt weil die
meisten leute die kaufen halt nix ich
glaube es gibt menschen die gehen jeden
tag drei stunden irgendwo einen
elektronischen fachgeschäft um zu gucken
ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt erst mal
ins auto dann erzähle ich euch noch ein
bisschen was ich habe jetzt aber auch
echt hunger als wenn man darauf achtet
man trifft so die verschiedensten
charaktere und auch so die
verschiedensten oder man nimmt bei
menschen halt so sehr komische
verhaltensmuster war auf die man oder
damals gar nicht wo wir sind die stunde
drüben glaubt und alex ist die ganze
zeit sein handy am ohr so richtig
auf jeden fall haben wir dann diese
familie dort gesehen
die taten irgendwie so ein bisschen leid
weil die ja auf jeden fall und die
musste auch ab und zu für ihre eltern
über setzen weil die leider nicht sehr
deutsch konnten und die tochter hat
eigentlich so komplett verhandeln das
war nicht schon krass also die war so
höchstens acht jahre und hat die ganze
zeit gefragt was er in dieser funktion
hat und sonst was wie teuer der ist
jetzt glaube ich wirklich gesagt wo
liegt der preislich das konnte ich mit
acht noch gar nicht der verein hat sie
das muss ich mir dann alles in der
schule gelernt fall schnell wenn die
eltern auf jeden fall haben ja gesehen
dass ich jetzt einen fernseher geworden
ich zeige euch den gleich ausführlich
und ich hab natürlich auch überlegt ob
wir dann noch was kaufmann der jetzt 270
euro gekostet das ding ist nur wir
hatten schon kurz darauf jetzt haben wir
schon kurz nach 8 und die haben uns
eigentlich so rausgeschmissen aber sie
haben gesagt der markt schließt jetzt
bitte raus und dann sind wir draußen
können wir auch lassen also es wirkt
groß so riesig war jetzt nicht aber ich
weiß nicht wir packen wir natürlich
jetzt vielleicht mal kurz aus leute was
gehabt guten morgen ja gäste nahmen habe
ich das video nicht mehr zu ende gefilmt
deswegen machen wir das jetzt ich hab
ich ja gesagt
ich werde sie auf jeden fall kurz mal
aus dass noch ganz wichtig damit ihr
seht was ich da eigentlich gekauft habe
weil ich habe das video schon ein
bisschen angefangen zu schneiden man
sieht auf dem handy aufnahmen kaum was
das für fernseher ist also man sieht nur
so ein bisschen die umrisse ihr habt ja
gestern schon gesehen
wer mehr den panasonic heft 300 also das
war der fernseher den die familie
gekauft hat wie schon gesagt der müsste
ungefähr war ich weiß nicht 270 über 250
euro gekostet haben also natürlich ist
es herzlich der beste smardtv mit 4k 8-k
was weiß ich aber schlecht ist auf jeden
fall was anderes ich glaube den kann man
sich ganz entspannen in sein zimmer
stellen
ihr könnt ich habe mir dieses
wunderschöne bild von köln und hier ist
dieser fernsehtisch die haben allerdings
keinen fernseher im wohnzimmer
warum wir ständig dem dahin dann kann
man direkt sehen wie das so aussehen
könnte
[Musik]
okay leute also das ist der fernseher
haben wir die fernbedienung batterien
logo auch dabei natürlich kann man die
nach auch so gesagt beim fernseh ständer
auf jeden fall haben wir hier ja so eine
halterung dafür dass man den da glaube
ich drauf stellen kann ich weiß jetzt
was das genau ist damit der wald steht
aber man kann ja schon sehen
so sieht irgendwie raus ich meine der 32
zoll also wie gesagt wenn ihr auf dem
bett liegt oder so sehen kann man
perfekt in jedes zimmer stellen ich find
auch in berlin aufmerksam und fernseher
wissen wollen wie schon gesagt das ist
das modell könnte er google also und
würde ich sogar eigentlich schon sagen
mehr gibt es nicht zu sagen abonniert
den kanal schreibt mir sehr gerne in
einem kommentar wie ich euch hier
erreichen kann
die gewinner werden dann im nächsten
part oder was heißt die gewinne nach der
gewinn habe ihr dann im nächsten part
von diesem format gezeigt vielleicht
komme ich auch persönlich vorbei je
nachdem wie weit ist müssen wir mal
schauen uns treibt die momentan wie ihr
euch erreichen kannst du nach oben dafür
weitere passt und schreibt auch sehr
gerne ideen für teilnahme macht das doch
mal im gucci store oder so kann man ja
auch als ich hoffe dass das find ich
fand es lustig haut rein das was von mir
und meinen reif automat verkauf ich
gerade auch also falls sie da
interessiert schreibt mir gerne mal eine
mail an meine geschäftliche mails findet
ihr auf youtube also leute genug
gelagert haut rein